if you dream of owning a big house and a
nice car you study hard and slowly climb
the ladder with pure effort and
determination but you need not work so
hard there's an easier way to make much
more money much much faster the door to
your success is in making a mobile game
in the keys we will soon discover but
you must be thinking isn't the market
already pretty flooded the answer is yes
incredibly but nearly all your
competition has failed miserably
too generous to original to honest
there's always more space for those that
carefully follow the lessons to come
just look at the hundreds of
best-selling slot machine apps each is
just a slightly different face to the
same basic game but they're all
incredibly successful candy crush makes
not one or five or fifty million dollars
a year but over a billion they're doing
something very right either candy crush
is the perfect realization of the art of
game design or it's really good at
exploiting your brain so what tricks of
psychology can we learn from the very
best you will soon find that they are no
more difficult than taking candy from a
child
[Music]
if you've ever played these games you
may have noticed that they all have
their own currency instead of paying
real money to save your characters life
or change his appearance
you pay with gems or coins or stars
which you first buy with real money this
is no accident by abstracting real money
into made-up currency players are
distanced from the consequences of their
choices I'm not paying two dollars for
this virtual hat I'm paying five hundred
coins which happened to cost two dollars
if you don't think anyone could possibly
be that stupid think again we all do
this to some extent when we see a ten
dollar item as simply costing one of
these and not what we're actually paying
with like say an hour of minimum wage
work casinos use this trick all the time
paying with tokens feels different than
paying with the same amount in dollars
and instead of constantly asking the
player to buy this or that with real
money tokens make the occasional moment
of weakness enough to make a handsome
profit so instead of selling one life
for $1 you can sell packs of coins the
cheapest of which is 2 or 5 or 10
dollars the player is forced to buy a
handful of coins when they only need a
few for what they really want the
smartest games multiply this effect to
create even more abstraction in clash of
clans you can buy gems which can be used
to buy gold which you can then use to
buy items the more indirect the more you
collect
every game has two kinds of players
those that play for free and a tiny
fraction that buys enough to make up for
everybody else your goal is to create as
many of that second category as possible
you want them to be dependent on your
game for satisfaction and to do that you
need to create routine the player who
pays a lot is the one who plays a lot in
the morning on the commute at the dinner
table everywhere reward players for
opening your app every day and create a
streak system that gives prizes for
playing X amount of days in a row it
doesn't take long before this creates a
regular habit some would say an
addiction and when it does players can
justify paying even more sure I'm
spending a ton but I play this game a
lot and don't let anyone escape your
grasp if you notice a player has taken a
break lure them back with a notification
or two or 30
people will happily pay for more levels
spins and characters but your ultimate
goal is to monetize everything if you
can make your players pay to play you
can also make them pay not to play if
you intentionally create annoyances and
time sinks parts of your game that are
no fun but necessary players will pay to
skip them it may sound ridiculous that
someone would pay money to play less of
the game they've paid for but it works
to your players it will feel like any
other purchase and you will make money
even when your game is boring win-win
if a casino has $1,000 for prize money
it would usually rather give $110 prizes
than a single thousand dollar prize too
much happiness at once leaves a player
satisfied more likely to cash out and
leave so - with your game your goal is
not to make your players happy you'll
often actually want to do the opposite
so space out the enjoyment of your game
enough to keep people interested but
never enough to truly satisfy and there
shouldn't be a single goal but a series
of objectives always replaced with
another when you complete the last the
most successful games aren't stories
with an arc and a gratifying ending but
eternal tasks with fake accomplishments
to take this a step further create many
similar games so there's always another
app for people to download a good
developer makes a single game which they
then change just enough to sell again
and again and again while the tone of
this video is sarcastic these are all
real tactics used by the most popular
games by understanding what they're
doing you're now less susceptible to
their deception but there's also more to
this story because it wasn't always this
bad when the App Store began it was
common to see five or ten dollar games
that sold quite well so what changed in
the nearly ten years since then and is
there a way to return to more honest
software these are big questions we'll
explore in an upcoming video so stay
tuned and thanks for watching